[موسيقى]
لندن تستعد لاحتضان الاحتفال بالتتويج ملك
البلاد الجديد تشارلز الثالث نحو 30 الف
ضابط يشاركون في تامين احتفال يوصف
بالتاريخي وهو تاريخي ايضا بالمعنى الامني
فالشرطه تعد واحدا من اكبر العمليات في
تاريخها ومع توسيع صلاحيتها من خلال قانون
النظام العام لتقييد المظاهرات حذرت
الشرطه من معاقبه كل من تسول له نفسه
تعكير الحدث
تمام
رسالتي لكل شخص يريد عرقله هذا الحدث هي
اننا لن نتسامح معه ابدا وسوف يواجهون
تحركا سريعا من قبلنا لضمان ان تمر هذه
الاحتفالات دون حوادث
الملكيه وامثالهم من انصار البيئه وغيرهم
يخشون استهدافهم بموجب القانون الجديد
الذي يقضي بسجن كل متظاهر يغلق الطرق لمده
قد تصل الى عام ويسمح للشرطه بتوقيف
وتفتيش كل من تشك في امره
وسنراه هو ان كثيرا من الناس يعتقلون
لاسباب تافهه اذا طبقت الشرطه القانون
الجديد وهو تجريم الاشخاص بمجرد وقوفهم في
الشارع دقيقتين هذا امر تافه بينما
التظاهر هو حق اساسي بالنسبه الينا وفي
الذي طلب فيه من البريطانيين تاكيد ولائهم
للملك الجديد يوم التتويج تبدي منظمات
حقوق الانسان قلقها من انكماش مساحه
الحريه في البلاد
الحق في التظاهر اساسي في كل ديمقراطيه
سليمه ونشطه ولكن رايناه خلال السنوات
الماضيه هو ان الحكومه سنت قوانين كثيره
تسمح للشرطه بتقييد المظاهرات اضافه الى
القانون الجديد الذي يفرض اجراءات قاسيه
للغايه ما ادى الى انكماش مساحه التظاهر
وهذا امر يثير قلقنا جميعا مع دخول
القانون الجديد حيز التنفيذي هذا الاسبوع
يبقى السؤال هل ستنجح الحكومه في اختبار
تحقيق التوازن بين الالتزام بمبادئ
الديمقراطيه وضمان امن احتفال تاريخي بحجم
تتويج ملك جديد للبلاد مينا حرب الجزيره
لندن